[Musique]
michel collon bonjour je vends recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle thinker view on aurait voulu
avoir votre regard sur la géopolitique
actuelle qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire première question qui êtes vous
je suis écrivain et journaliste
indépendant dehors du système des médias
j'ai commencé à travailler
après une carrière comme carrière d'un
vilain mot mais après un travail comme
journaliste sur les luttes sociales en
belgique puisque je suis basé à
bruxelles ou à liège et j'ai commencé à
travailler sur ce qui est devenu mon
thème central les guerres les stratégies
de guerre et les stratégies de
désinformation pour moi ça va ensemble
avec un livre qui s'appelait attention
médias sur la première guerre du golfe
contre l'irak
attention médias forcément je me suis
pas fait que des amis encore que il ya
eu quand même un intérêt de la part de
certains services publics on va dire
surtout sur
salaire en 90 91 ça a été le festival
des médiamensonges de la désinformation
autour de 1000 heures de direct au cours
de la guerre d'irak les couveuses volé
dans une maternité c'était bidon saddam
hussein avait provoqué une marée noire
et michel chevalet sur tf1
présenté par poivre 10 à regarder saddam
hussein comme il est méchant il a fait
délibérément envahir le golfe là par une
marée noire et des mots louis daily
deals l'histoire des bébés dans les
couveuses l'histoire des bébés dans les
couveuses c'est est ce si ça se passait
en novembre 90 et à une commission
denquête dépendant du congrès aux etats
unis
il y à une jeune fille de 15 ans qui
vient témoigner en disant voilà elle
pleure toutes les larmes de son corps il
dit j'étais
infirmière à koweit city la capitale
occupée alors par les troupes irakiennes
le plus de trois mois et je travaille
dans cette maternité et un jour les
soldats irakiens sont venus ils ont pris
tout les couveuses il y en avait 32 et
ils ont jeté les bébés par terre et
comme s'il est prématuré forcément est
condamné à une mort atroce et donc voilà
les irakiens c'est vraiment une
occupation épouvantable donc le jeune
fils je verrai c'était le sens père
c'était la jeune fille donc
forcément c'est une histoire qui a été
popularisé mitterrand n'a parlé bush en
a parlé amnesty a fait des rapports le
vol de couveuses c'était donc un
argument de choc pour des il faut aller
écraser ce saddam hussein qui n'épargne
même pas des bébés et après la guerre
évidemment tous les journalistes quand
le co a été libérée de l'occupation on
va dire tous les journalistes se
précipitent à la maternité on va voir un
scoop on va voir les confidences de tous
ces médecins qui ont assisté à ça et le
les médecins disent beaucoup veulent
sont là il s'est rien passé il s'est
rien passé du tout la jeune fille était
en fait la fille de l'ambassadeur
du koweït à washington à l'onu elle est
à new york pendant l onu l était pas
plus infirmières que vous et moi elle
avait passé toute sa dernière année là
avec son père et c'était une totale mise
en scène par une firme qui de public et
la chine ce qui s'appelle hélène
knowlton il y en a toute une série aux
états unis qui font ça et en fait c'est
quoi ces déchirures de com qui se charge
de donner une image positive à des
gouvernements étrangers
israël fait ça larbi l'afrique de
l'arabie saoudite eut et l'afrique du
sud faisait ça au temps de l'apartheid
et le koweït faisait ça évidemment
donner une image positive du koweït
s'était pas évident donc on a plutôt
fait dans la diabolisation saddam
hussein et on a complètement fabriqué
cette histoire de découvrir ce volet et
ça c'est un festival de médiamensonge
puis j'ai donc là on est résumé dans en
étant 90 ça c'est le point de départ de
mon travail là et après 91 vous êtes
arrêté sur cour mais après il ya eu la
guerre contre la yougoslavie en deux
phases d'abord en bosnie en croatie
bosnie 91 à 95 puis pendant 99 la guerre
soit disant pour libérer le kosovo ayant
milité pour détruire la yougoslavie qui
était un pays indépendant
une armée indépendante qui voulaient pas
entrer dans le temps et un pays où il y
avait pas mal de choses qui n'allaient
pas mais il y avait aussi des choses qui
allaient pas mal et notamment il y avait
une sécurité sociale importante il y
avait une sécurité d'emploi dans les
entreprises les travailleurs élisaient
leur directeur donc ça quand les
multinationales ont
quand il ya eu la chute du mur la chute
du socialisme à l'est la yougoslavie
était le seul pays qui résistaient qui
se mettait pas à genoux devant les
multinationales donc j'ai montré dans
deux livres poker-menteur et monopoly le
temps la conquête du monde qu'en fait
c'était une guerre de recolonisation des
zones qui avaient été perdus et donc moi
je travaille sur ce
sur ce tableau n'avait pas prévu au
départ de faire sable le livre attention
médias très bien marché c'était la
première fois qu'on faisait une analyse
critique de médias en europe il y avait
aux états unis et remanie chomsky qui
avait publié un bouquin qui m'avait
inspiré qui était très important il
s'appelle manufacturing 100 la
fabrication du consentement c'est à dire
qu'ils avaient fait un genre de test
médias il analysait la couverture des
deux camps dans les grands médias des
états unis
quantitativement déjà et puis aussi
qualitativement dans l'analyse ça ça
m'avait inspiré et j'avais décidé
d'appliquer sa à cette guerre du golfe
en 90 91 et après comme ça il beaucoup
de succès beaucoup d'impact les gens
étaient très curieux sur justement est
ce que les médias manipulent à ce moment
là bas les états unis n'ont pas arrêté
de me donner du travail puisque à cette
époque là on nous avait annoncé un
nouvel ordre mondial il y aura plus de
guerre etc et puis les guerres sont pas
arrêtés et donc j'ai couvert ça plus la
libye puis d'autres et c'est devenu un
peu ma spécialité de base comme écrivain
on va dire donc le problème de gratter
giguère et la propagande donc la
stratégie de guerre qu'est ce que vous
pouvez me dire de carl von clausewitz
en ruban un spécialiste mais
je vois que
la guerre se déroule sur différents
terrains et en fait moi je dis toujours
naguère ne commence pas par des bons
mais par des médias mensonges et je
pense qu'il ya maintenant du côté des
états unis oui surtout une stratégie de
guerre globale
la guerre se déroule en réalité
face à
l'ennemi
direct déclaré on va envahir tel pays
pas l'envahir on va protéger des
minorités ou écarter un danger
terroriste ou voilà mais en réalité il
faut viser pas seulement comme on le
prétend les dirigeants ce pays faut
diriger visé pardon la population qui
n'a pas forcément envie d'être colonisés
ou recoloniser et puis il faut viser
l'opinion publique internationale donc
pour que les états unis ou la france en
afrique puisse déclencher une guerre le
premier ennemi c'est l'opinion publique
intérieure il faut absolument la
neutraliser il faut l'empêcher de
s'opposer à cette guerre parce que quand
on regarde dans le passé il ya eu
beaucoup de guerres qui ont été arrêtés
ou freiné par la résistance
internationale dans ma génération on a
été marquée par la guerre l'agression
des etats-unis contre le vietnam qui a
commencé en 61 qui a duré jusqu'en 75 et
elle a été freinée pourquoi les états
unis ont mis le paquet c'était à
l'époque la plus grande puissance
économique financière militaire de
l'histoire on peut dit fais jamais un
arsenal militaire pareil et le vietnam
c'était quoi un pays de paysans des pays
pauvres de paysans très peu développé
cause du colonialisme et donc à la fin
c'est david qui a gagné ses quatre
collègues qui est parti la queue entre
les jambes parce que les vietnamiens
étaient bien soudée on va dire avec des
dirigeants honnêtes ça compte beaucoup
pas corrompus qui avait vraiment une
vision de la libération qui avait aussi
vraiment une vision d' unir toutes les
forces possibles les communistes les
houthis les chrétiens des différentes
classes sociales contre l'occupation et
2 le facteur qui a permis que les etats
unis soient vaincus c'est la
mobilisation internationale faisait des
manifs pour contre la guerre au début il
y avait quelques centaines de personnes
et finalement on a eu des manifs de
centaines de milliers de personnes et
les états unis ont été complètement
démasqué là dessus donc qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez vous dire autour d'une
affaire qui s'appelle la sphère du golfe
du tonkin ah oui intéressante moi je dis
que chaque guerre commence pas par des
mots mais par un médiamensonge et dans
le cas de la baie du tonkin
les états unis s'étaient johnson je
pense à l'époque avait décidé
d'intensifier
leurs opérations et ils ont dit voilà
les deux navires us dans la baie du
tonkin ont été attaqués par les
vietnamiens et donc nous ripostons ça
c'est un classique de la propagande de
guerre c'est jamais nous qui attaquons
c'est les méchants qui attaque et nous
on est dans l'ue en légitime défense et
après les etats-unis ont reconnu que
l'incident de la baie du tonkin avait
été complètement inventé et fabriqué de
toutes pièces chaque guerre est basé sur
un médiamensonge et ça c'est quelque
chose que j'ai analysé pour l'irak pour
la yougoslavie pour la libye un gros
truc qui est monopolisée dans la
communication de guerre et qui doit
faire basculer l'opinion il faut faire
quelque chose est ce que vous avez
entendu parler d'une opération qui
s'appelle l'opération northwoods
miss et l'irak celle avec le contrat get
sa c'est
à peu près la même époque c'est au tour
de tubes heures on en reparlera oui je
mettrai les liens et très bien donc les
médiamensonges à la base d'une guerre
pour retourner l'opinion publique
on est en 2016 qu'est-ce que vous avez
relevés en ce moment que médiamensonges
bas sur la guerre il ya deux choses 1 en
ressasse les médiamensonges d'ailière
précédentes qui ont pourtant été
complètement démasqué et ça c'est
frappant sur la libye par exemple que
j'ai suivie puisque j'ai été deux fois
là-bas pendant les bombardements j'ai
fait une enquête j'ai fait un livre qui
s'appelle libye autant et médiamensonges
et là moi je disais à l'époque un
s'est basé sur des médiamensonges
d'origine à savoir que kadhafi aurait
bombardé la population qui manifestait
complètement fou c'était une invention 2
qu' il aurait envoyé des containers de
viagra pour
stimuler ses soldats pour violer en
masse comme instrument de terreur de la
population ça c'est un classique les
viols de guerre c'est un classique de la
propagande de guerre évidemment quand
j'ai été en
libye et que j'ai raconté cette histoire
est mon rayonner en dix ans via grave
connaît pas douce et gingembre et sanaa
c'était complètement bidon et
ça c'est au niveau des médiamensonges
justificateur et puis j'ai dit à
l'époque dans les premiers articles et
puis avait après il ya eu ce livre j'ai
dit c'est une guerre évidemment pour le
pétrole de kadhafi c'est une guerre pour
les réserves très importantes il y avait
30 milliards de revenus chaque année du
pétrole pour des pays en crise comme les
états unis à la france c'est un butin
j'ai dit c'est lors de kadhafi qui est
placé dans les banques des etats-unis
qui vont jamais
rendre et c'est pour empêcher kadhafi de
financer des projets de développement
alternatif de pays africains pour
échapper au chantage et multinationales
et du fmi évidemment mon dieu c'est un
comploteur ils voient le mal partout
bien sûr que les états unis et sarko
font une guerre humanitaire est
maintenant dans les emails révélé de
madame clinton elle dit oui c'est un
sarko il faisait la guerre parce qu'il
voulait le pétrole ils avaient des
accords pour total et 2 c'est un bonne
raison de faire la guerre à kadhafi pour
son magot son nord quoi aujourd'hui
kadhafi cela représentait combien
hausses étaient des sommes très
importantes parce qu'elle habib sy était
un des je vais plus oser dire un chiffre
mais je les mets dans mon bouquin je
suis mauvais sur les chiffres mais
c'était très important pour une raison
bien simple la libye était un pas un des
rares pays au monde sans dette le
wyeomyia gaïa saddam est certes lors
c'était intéressant nous moi je suis là
l'aspect plutôt sur les fonds souverains
qui représente beaucoup plus en masse de
dollars si je peux parler en termes de
masse au dollar qu'à la réalité de leur
physique de cas mais je pense que les
faux le fonds souverain libyen
d'investissement étranger était beaucoup
plus important que l'ue ait meilleure
solution d'accord donc la libye la libye
ça c'est fait la syrie
au niveau médiamensonges bas
c'est quelque chose qu'on a suivi dans
le site investis en actions et notamment
publiant les travaux les enquêtes de bar
qui mesure qui est un belge d'origine
turque mais de la communauté proche de
la syrie qui a suivi ce dossier en
permanence et en fait oui on a eu comme
d'habitude des médiamensonges pour
justifier en fait une guerre qu'il
voulait mener contre la syrie mais par
des méthodes indirectes et les
médiamensonges s'était notamment de
montrer des cadavres et des choses bien
atroce comme on fait toujours dans
chaque guerre pour
jouer sur les émotions du public et de
dire voilà c'est bachar qui l'a fait et
dans beaucoup des cas de photos qui ont
été publiées c'est l inverse je ne dis
pas que l'homme chimie les troupes de
bachar était ce sont des anges toujours
il ya eu des atrocités il ya eu des
crimes c'est incontestable mais très
souvent montré des photos en disant
voilà les victimes de bachelard mais non
c'était les soldats tués par les
rebelles justement ça c'est très
frappant au niveau des armes chimiques
personnes nées des anges dans ce conflit
mais il ya une chose qui est il faut
toujours voir à qui ça profite de ce
genre de choses le moment où ça se passe
c'est le moment où les l'opposition et
rebelle est en grande difficulté sur le
plan militaire c'est le moment où
la syrie a accepté que viennent une
mission de l'onu pour mission de bons
offices pour mettre fin au conflit et
juste à ce moment là comme par hasard
sous les yeux des inspecteurs bachar
aurait été utilisé les armes chimiques
à quelques kilomètres de l'endroit où
ils sont donc ça c'est un truc classique
en réalité il ya eu beaucoup de
documents des états unis et notamment de
seymour arch
la lisez aussi action extrêmement
important aux états unis qui a beaucoup
de confidences de l'establishment
militaire qui a dit non ça c'est
complètement vide vous parlez vous
parlez des états unis
est-ce que vous avez suivi la sphère de
l'anthrax des mails d'anthrax
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
les principes de la propagande de guerre
c'est de cacher l'histoire cachée les
intérêts économiques
diaboliser effrayer
inverser la victime et
l'agresseur et l'agressé monopolisé le
débat se censurer les informations
adverse dans la diabolisation
il faut absolument flanquer la trouille
c'est quelque chose que michael moore a
bien montré dans bowling for columbine
où il montre que bush dans sa croisade
pour attaquer au départ et vous
l'attaquez encore beaucoup plus de pays
qu'est ce qu'il a fait il avait vraiment
besoin de flanquer la trouille aux
citoyens des états unis avec le
terrorisme et évidemment ce cinéma sur
l'anthrax et sur les armes de
destruction massive tout ça c'est au
même moment ce sont des recettes il ya
je parlais de public relations
il ya des psy ops en bretagne et aux
états unis là c'est même assez ouvert
fine del toro voilà des experts de la
manipulation psychologique
et ces gens là sont des pros c'est à
dire que il analyse quels sont les
thèmes qui peuvent marcher pour flanquer
la trouille pour justifier une guerre je
sais pas si vous avez vu un film qui
s'appelle wag the dog aux états unis qui
a filmé très intéressant où un président
c'est du jour dans les années 90 quand
un président est en déclin dans les
sondages de ce qu' il a couché avec une
fille c est ça se peut pas là bas et il
il faut absolument qu'ils remontent
l'élection c'est bientôt il doit
remonter dans les sondages donc ces
experts en com et observent des sit il
faut un ennemi le problème c'est que
pour le moment il n'y a aucune tension
particulière il n'y a pas d
apparemment gros conflit donc on va
fabriquer un ennemi et quel pays ça peut
être celui-là nom de draps et donc
finalement décide que ça va être
l'albanie et on va vers l'albanie parce
que personne ne connaissait même pas
très bien où c'est et donc on va pouvoir
fabriquer et alors je crois que c'est
des niro hoffman je sais pas mais il ya
donc un scénariste de hollywood qui est
chargée de fabriquer et ils inventent
des images où on voit une petite fille
avec des flammes derrière et un pauvre
petit chat est donc c'est tourné en
studio mais s'est présenté comme étant
la pauvre petite fille qui échappe aux
atrocités des méchants il faut que les
états unis aïe protéger cette pauvre
petite fille et son chat et le film très
intéressant parce qu'il montre vraiment
la fabrication de l'ennemi la
fabrication de la trouille et bien
entendu à la fin les scénaristes et
assassinées parce que il faut pas qu'on
sache le président ça marche le
président remonte dans les sondages
c'est bien entendu le scénariste va
mourir au milieu de tout ça de tous
cette propagande de guerre commence
situe la france vous avec votre
nationalité belge comment vous nous
voyez les français
les français ça n'existe pas je sais pas
si vous parlez de hollande valls et de
bhl ou si vous parlez des gens qu'on
vient de rencontrer dans la rue c'est
savoir vous et moi oui ben je pense que
malheureusement
les français ont un gouvernement qui
travaille contre leurs intérêts quels
sont les intérêts des français les
intérêts des français c'est que c'est
d'avoir du travail d'avoir un revenu
correct pouvoir donner un avenir à ses
enfants pouvoir se payer des soins de
santé c'est avoir une vie un peu correct
ce qui est financièrement et
techniquement tout à fait possible il ya
bien assez de richesses qui sont
produites pour que tout le monde vive
bien on est dans une situation un an à
situation par dans l'abominable
maintenant la moitié des gens
travaillent comme des dingues et sont
stressés font des heures sup et prennent
des pilules pour tenir le coup et
l'autre moitié des gens sont au chômage
sous-employé et prennent des pilules
parce qu'ils sont des primes il faut
absolument organiser la vie économique
sociale en fonction des besoins des gens
et pas en fonction des profits de
quelques multinationales
ça c'est un système infernal
l'intérêt des français comme des belges
et comme tout le monde à mon avis c'est
de vivre bien de vivre correctement il
ya déjà une première mesure qui devrait
être faite puisqu'à part du travail pour
tout le monde parce que heureusement les
techniques les technologies
l'informatique ont progressé on doit
travailler beaucoup moins qu'avant
partage de travail tout le monde
travaille 20 heures tout le monde sera
content et on pourra s'occuper de ces
gosses de la culture voyages et faire du
sport ce qu'on a envie je vois c'est
l'intérêt des gens un jour un jour je
discutais quelqu'un qui est censé
cerveau bien fait il m'a dit tu sais
cg ballon c'est pourquoi le la
démographie nuit à la qualité des
cerveaux
qu'est ce que vous pouvez me dire de
cette phrase démographie nuit à la
qualité des cerveaux il veut dire que
s'il ya trop de si on fabrique trop de
gosse on sera plus bête ou je sais pas
je n'ai pas la réponse il faudra lui
demander à lui rue mais pour revenir à
la question importante
l'intérêt des français n'est pas le même
que l'intérêt du 1 % qui accumule des
fortunes je pense à merlaut qui pillent
l'afrique je pense que les draps gala
qui fabrique des destructions de mort et
qui sait fabriquer une fortune là dessus
je pense à des gens connus beaux draps
qui licencient des gens à tour de bras
ya cumul des fortunes dont ils savent
pas quoi faire l'intérêt des 99% il est
exactement contraires aux intérêts du 1%
et on a de plus en plus de fortune on à
85 personnes qui peut s'être autant que
la moitié de l'humanité c'est un système
absurde ça peut pas continuer les gens
peuvent pas être heureux dans un système
comme ça et le problème c'est que les
guerres sont des guerres pour le 1 %
parce que qui a intérêt à aller
contrôler les minerais en afrique le
pétrole au moyen-orient les marchés et
les forêts l'eau et ses acquis et
intérêts vous moi non nous on peut très
bien vivre avec ce qu'il ya ici et en
ayant des relations normales équitable
fraternelle avec les autres peuples mais
les gens qui ont besoin de toujours plus
de fric pas pour le plaisir ou parce
qu'ils sont méchants mais parce que
s'ils ne font pas le concurrent va les
éliminer regardez toutes ces fusions de
multinationales toutes ces boîtes dont
l'unique obsession c'est d'être les
meilleurs d i mean et les autres les
avaler et des toujours plus gros et ça
sert à quoi ça sert à produire des trucs
inutiles des de gaspiller les ressources
de la nature et rend les gens malheureux
parce qu'ils travaillent trop souvent
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de travail c'est
ça qui doit changer et les guerres sont
malheureusement une manière de faire
main basse sur les matières premières
les marchés la main d'oeuvre aussi donc
c'est deguire poule 1 % donc comment se
positionne la france autour tout ça la
france est suivi ce la france essaye de
louvoyer pour essayer de faire entendre
sa voix la france se trouve est-ce que
c'est une question importante scène qui
sont d'un français ça mais très
forcément elle est importante alors
c'est mort mais
bon la france a eu en fait sur l'élite
française à deux tendances il ya une
tendance qui voudrait bien garder son
pré carré en afrique sa zone d'influencé
et qui essayerait d'être plus
indépendants par rapport aux états unis
dans le sens
il ya eu un moment donné des tendances
en france et en allemagne à faire une
euros armée qui serait indépendante de
l'autre et ça j'en ai parlé dans le
livre l'euro 2011 à l'otan à la conquête
du monde que les états unis de textes de
wolf ovitz des textes de plc qui est de
brzezinski aussi qui disait il faut
absolument empêcher l'europe d'avoir son
armée d'être indépendante d'ailleurs la
guerre de compte la yougoslavie dont on
a parlé précédemment
c'était pas seulement une guerre quand
il veut cela vie c'est une guerre pour
empêcher la france de s'entendre avec
l'allemagne et avec la russie pour que
l'europe devienne indépendante donc il
ya cette tendance là dans l'élite
française il ya aussi la tendance sarko
hollande etc qui s'est complètement
alignée sur les états unis complètement
j'exagère mais qui s'est alignée sur les
états unis qui pensent que en étant le
numéro deux là dedans il y aura des bons
morceaux du gâteau a récupéré en quoi il
se fout le doigt dans l'oeil parce que
quand la france possède et contrôle une
colonie et des richesses en afrique les
états unis financent des politiques et
surtout des mouvements pour déclencher
des guerres civiles déstabilisé ça donc
les états unis font semblant d'être
allié avec la france en afrique mais en
réalité il la poignarde dans le dos
régulièrement comment se comportent les
médias autour de tout ça c'est à dire
qu'il ya médiatique tiers on a compris
que ces médiamensonges saurai où semble
être
construits par des cabinets de spin
doctor who de
de propagande médiatique pays
le journaliste du service public belge
ou français
portugais et espagnols
il se comporte comme en face à ça il a
encore son esprit critique d'abord la
question à ce qu'elle porte sur les
médias ou sur les journalistes les deux
le jour 2 les journalistes est-ce que
c'est eux qui décident dans les médias
moi j'ai toujours la distinction je
crois qu'il ya différentes catégories de
journalistes y en a des qui sont très
curieux et honnêtes et qui sert est
vraiment de faire passer des choses le
problème c'est que dans les médias c'est
pas le journaliste qui ont le pouvoir
c'est le patron tout simplement comme
dans toute entreprise et il faut voir
que au niveau international et au niveau
français c'est très clair qui possède
les grands quotidiens ou les grandes
télés ce sont tous ces milliardaires
vous avez
marchand d'art vous avez et roland
pierre de l'afrique vous avez régal
marchands d'armes vous avez
qui qui est un des personnes les plus
riches en israël vous avez vous invite
tous ces gens là donc l'info que les
genres soir que les 99% ressort est
faite par les 1 % en fonction de leurs
intérêts alors vous allez me dire oui
mais c'est pas parce qu'il est patron
qui va mettre à la porte le journaliste
qui lui déplaît bien si on a plein
d'exemples justement où des journalistes
n'ont pas pu exprimer vous en dis
carrément viré un exemple qui est pas
révolutionnaire de gauche dans paris
match quand genestar qui était le
rédac'chef le directeur je crois à
l'époque publie des photos montrant que
la femme de sarko est pas allé voter à
la fameuse élection présidentielle de
2007 ce qui est une info franchement un
petit peu anecdotique et les virées pour
ça parce que sarko téléphone et direct
le patron vire le rédac'chef des proches
des seuils des preuves de ses généraux
avaient été reconnus c'est alain
genestar c'était tout à fait reconnu
absolument donc c'est le patron qui
décide et je vais mais l'analyse comme
je parlais tout à l'heure de hermann et
chomsky a mené une analyse importante
qui est que l'info elle est filtrée de
différentes manières il n'y a pas que la
propriété il ya aussi la publicité c'est
à dire que maintenant pouvait lancer un
quotidien mais supposons qu'on le vende
un euro ou un euro cinquante en réalité
le coût de fabrication est deux à trois
fois plus important ça veut dire que
c'est pas en payant votre quotidien que
vous le payez c'est l'annonceur qui
payent le quotidien ça veut dire que en
fait on vend un acheteur à un annonceur
et les budgets de la publicité c'est
quoi c'est le pétrole c'est les bagnoles
c'est procter gamble et sous ces machins
là c'est pas le coiffeur du coin qui
fait vivre les grands journaux ou la
télé donc la publicité c'est un traître
est un filtre très important le
troisième fils très important ce sont
les relations entre les pouvoirs
économiques politiques et médiatiques et
un très bon bouquin malheureusement
épuisé de geoffrey geuens tous pouvoirs
confondus
où il analyse toutes les grandes
multinationales
européennes et des états unis et il
montre l'enchevêtrement au niveau des
actionnaires et au niveau des
administrateurs vraiment toutes les
multinationales nationale pardon sont
les unes dans les autres et au niveau
des médias c'est très frappant j'ai
publié dans un bouquin en résumé de ce
qu'il avait travaillé et qui montre que
dans les médias aux états unis on a les
multinationales de la banque de la
chimie du pétrole de l'armement etc qui
sont dans les médias donc on a des
relations très étroites et puis il ya
des relations de copinage on va dire et
d'élitisme entre les grands directeurs
les journalistes vedettes
et les pouvoirs politiques et
économiques et le quatrième filtre doit
pas être négligé c'est la question de
l'idéologie dominante parce que je n'ai
pas voulu dire je ne dirai jamais que
tous les journalistes sont pourris plein
de journalistes essaient de faire
correctement leur métier 1 en général on
leur laisse pas le temps d'investiguer
de faire des enquêtes il faut produire
vite c'est un travail à la chaîne en
fait et 2 il ya quand même aussi ce
phénomène de l'idéologie on vit dans une
société on a été formé dans les corps
journalistes ont aussi bien dans l'info
qui est diffusé et ça c'est une
idéologie une logique dominante un
patron d'un journaliste vedette de tf1
disait au moment de la guerre du golfe
là non je parlais la première disait
voilà nous avons d'un côté le monde
civilisé et de l'autre côté le monde
arabe textuellement à l'antenne donc on
est dans une pensée extrêmement raciste
et colonialiste ça restera très fort
régis debray avait dit cette phrase que
j'aime beaucoup de cités parlant
justement de ce phénomène de ils
disaient
ils ont enlevé leur casque mais dessous
la tête et rester coloniale le mode de
pensée reste celui de l'europe et un
blanc supérieure avec ses valeurs et que
les arabes les noirs doivent apprendre
de l'européen civilisé sur votre chaîne
youtube vous avez annoncé
un ou deux mois que laurent fabius et le
gouvernement de françois hollande était
responsable des attentats avec
le bataclan je crois bien par le fait
qu'ils aient financé le terrorisme oui
parce que vous pouvez rentrer plusieurs
détails oui ça me vient pas de moi hein
ça vient de différents enquêteurs dont
de nouveau ses mots un skate un
journaliste très très intéressant qui
devrait vraiment être aux états unis
donc qui devrait vraiment être diffusé
parce qu'il a les confidences de gens de
l'establishment par exemple quand obama
ou clinton décide une guerre vous avez
des généraux qui sont pas d'accord qui
disent on peut pas la gagner ou ça va
provoquer des effets pire est donc qui
balancent des choses et c'est mon heure
j'avais effectivement
avait fait des révélations par rapport à
tout ça
si vous avez fait des révélations par
rapport à tout ça il avait dit quoi
la question c'est est pourquoi vous
incriminez la rhf abuse voilà dans les
attentats voilà et lui donc c'est maurer
a annoncé que en fait
ce qu'on a appelé les yeux rougis à dist
ces jeunes qui par ce matin en syrie le
mode ia ne convient pas parce que dans
le coran le djihad c'est essentiellement
le combat avec soi-même pour être un
homme plus justes donc ça n'a rien à
voir mais ces jeunes dont qui ont été
envoyés là bas ça a été un travail
organisé
par la cia avec des camps d'entraînement
il a donné les dates et
non des lieux mêmes les instructeurs
ça a été financée par l'arabie saoudite
et le qatar nos chers amis investisseurs
dans notre économie dans nos clubs
sportifs et dans nos restaurants et
prédicateurs de haine un peu partout
s'est passé par la turquie et donc on a
eu ce phénomène que les états unis et la
france avaient décidé de renverser le
gouvernement de bachar al assad c'est le
plan de recolonisation de l'ensemble du
moyen-orient après la libye c'était la
syrie puis ce sera le hamas le hezbollah
et ils voulaient l'iran mais ça ça va
être plus difficile en tout cas la
résistance palestinienne il faut la
priver du tout ses arrières et donc
cette opération là ça a été en fait
étant donné que les états unis obama a
compris l'échec de bouche il n'est plus
question d'envoyer des troupes us au sol
comme en irak ou en afghanistan
ça coûte cher on n'en sort pas et on
devient une cible donc on fait la guerre
par proxy mort comme ils disent en
anglais c'est à dire par intermédiaire
ça peut être des pays voisins ou des
mouvements sécessionnistes ça ça marche
parfois mais en syrie avait pas les
forces pour faire ça donc les seules
forces qu'ils ont trouvé c'est de
constituer une armée de rhodia nice
quand même 35 mille venus de toute une
série de pays avec l'argent de l'arabie
saoudite et du qatar pour financer ça et
c'est pas nouveau c'est exactement ce
qui avait été fait contre l'afghanistan
l'opération ben laden
régine ski dont je parle avait organisé
et c'est en fait une opération ben laden
bis donc quand j'ai dit que fabius et
compagnie étaient responsables des
attentats de paris c'est parce qu'en
fait ces gens là ces gens qui ont fait
ça ont été envoyés en syrie pour faire
ça contre la population syrienne parce
qu'on massacre des chrétiens d musulman
donc là c'est un show qui se retourne
contre le crb moi c'est frankenstein
exactement comment vous voyez le 3 2
prochaines années
sur le prisme de lecture terroriste de
cette grande nébuleuse terroriste
sur le plan du terrorisme je pense que
c'est devenu une arme privilégiée des
états unis et de leurs alliés mais c'est
les états unis qui sont le maître
d'oeuvre là dedans pourquoi pas c'est
comme je le disais les états unis n'ose
plus envoyé leurs troupes occuper un
pays comme il faisait avant ça ils
s'exposent ça coûte cher ça soude la
population contre eux donc ce n'est pas
productif
donc on est obligé de trouver des
remplacements alors évidemment ils ont
essayé aussi de faire en sorte que les
européens se battent pour eux et finance
une partie de leurs gains mais ça ça
marche moyen donc on essaie de trouver
des puissances locale parfois ça marche
il sera évidemment il vit sur
l'industrie de guerre donc israël ne
demande que ça la colombie était aussi
un peu l'israël de l'amérique latine on
veut dire l'ethiopie est aussi dans la
corne de l'afrique est une région
stratégique c'est aussi un pays qui sert
de deux flics local on va dire aux états
unis mais il ya des limites à ça aussi
et donc maintenant le terrorisme c'est
vraiment une arme privilégiée et c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est un psychiatre
célèbre en france qui s'appelle boris
cyrulnik il a fait une déclaration très
peu de temps après l'attentât contre
charlie qui était très significative on
lui demandait j'imagine qu'en tant que
psychiatre qu'il a dû avoir des jeunes
ou des familles de jeunes qui sont venus
voir en grand partie là-bas et moi j'ai
rencontré des moments dont les gosses
sont partis là bas est ce que vous dire
que c'est vraiment humainement quelque
chose d'horrible à entendre et donc
suffire sur l'ia rencontrer des gens et
donc il était révolté par la façon de
parler de l'histoire de charlie en
noyant le poisson et en ne parlant pas
des vrais problèmes
qui est responsable
de cette chose là et si le journaliste
lui disais mais c'est renier disait ce
sont des filières très organisés qui
recrutent les jeunes avec un lavage de
cerveau ça je l' ai vu aussi les
méthodes qui son poids pour on prend des
jeunes de 15 16 17 ans qui sont en
adolescence ou pau mais c'est facile de
manipuler et donc cyrulnik disait cd
filière bien organisée alors je ne me
suis dit fier de qui est dit par les
gens du pétrole et de la drogue très
clairement parce que c'est un moyen pas
cher pour déstabiliser des gouvernements
et contrôler des régions et des
ressources donc je crois que c'est ça le
point fondamental c'est que le
gouvernement français et ses alliés ne
sont pas la solution face au problème du
terrorisme ils sont la cause du problème
et les états unis qui sont évidemment
les m 2 sont ceux qui utilisent à une
grande échelle le terrorisme il faut
rappeler qu ils l'ont fait contre cuba
qu'ils ont fait contre le venezuela
condé pays latino américains on a
financé les coûts de la cia pour faire
exploser un avion avec des sportifs
cubains ou dans des hôtels à l'avenir
entre les réfugiés à miami les gens
qu'est ce qui va vous pouvez nous parler
des rezzous gladio oui ben les réseau
gladio pour les jeunes c'est un
phénomène très important dans les années
50 au moment de la guerre froide moi
j'ai vécu ça j'étais petit garçon dans
les années 50 on été éduqué dans les
russes vont nous attaquer les russes
vont envahir l'europe et on va tous
devenir être obligé de l'économie russe
a dû tout venir les russes être
communiste on devra on va perdre notre
maison va perdre voiture rendre à
partager les femmes parce que c'était on
était vraiment dans les trucs
incroyables sur la propagande portait
jamais les hommes ainsi que leurs
annonces et vraiment c'est fort et donc
on a
organisé
à organiser des réseaux pour le cas où
il y aurait des gouvernements de gauche
qui viendraient en europe c'est surtout
la france et l'italie un peu la belgique
aussi parce que
années 50 après 40 45 le capitalisme a
produit la deuxième guerre mondiale les
patrons en france ont beaucoup collaboré
avec le nazisme en belgique sont
réfugiées allons dans le temps donc ça
finit où ont collaboré à bruxelles aussi
et donc les gens ont compris que la
guerre mondiale est le produit du
capitalisme en tant que lutte pour la
suprématie mondiale les matières
premières les colonies que c'est une
guerre pour le fric tout simplement les
réseau gladio et donc ils cherchent aux
jo et les réseau gladio c'est au cas où
ces gens décideraient qui veulent un
gouvernement de gauche avec des
communistes on va faire des attentats on
va déstabiliser le pays on va semer la
terreur pour les eu des attentats et il
ya eu des attentats il ya eu des
attentats de la v50 il ya eu des
attentats à la gare de bologne avec je
crois 280 ou 300 morts on a mis des
bombes à la gare de bologne et qu'est ce
qu'on a dit c'est les anarchistes et
donc ça sert à faire passer des lois
répressives contre la gauche est en
réalité ce été reconnu par un
organisateur de l'attentât en réalité
c'était une provocation des réseau
gladio et de l'otan pour semer le bordel
en italie flanquer la trouille on
revient à ce qu'on avait abordé tout à
l'heure aux italiens allait il nous faut
un gouvernement de droite il faut des
lois très fort donc c'est là le recours
au terrorisme pour déstabilise vous avez
vu en france on a eu récemment une
grande campagne contre les théories du
complot les complotistes et les gascons
aluminium
est-ce que vous pensez que puisque notre
histoire n'est pas assez énoncer
clairement comme lé réseau gladio comme
les gens ne savent pas ça est ce que
cette antériorité l'historique est
utilisé par les mots ce que ce que nous
on appelle les nouveaux gourous tease
voilà lé réseau gladio bas ils nous ont
mis à l'envers les attentats coulibaly
c'est la même chose alors nous on n'est
pas du tout d'accord avec cette vision
là l'histoire de le le rétroviseur qui
passe du noir à l'argent mais c'était
pas la bonne voiture mais on n'est pas
trop d'accord avec ça on est pas même du
tout d'accord avec ça est-ce que vous
pensez que pour supprimer certaines
théories du complot il faudrait se
retourner sur notre passé pour expliquer
aux gens ça s'est produit mais là sur ce
coup là c'est pas le cas
qu'est ce que vous en pensez tout à fait
je pense qu'à la question des complots
du complotisme des obsédés la théorie du
complot d'une question importante
je suis en train de travailler là dessus
et ça va sortir bientôt
en fait il faut dire un que les complots
ça existe je veux dire quand tu es etats
unis organisent le renversement die and
et pour le remplacer par le fascisme
pinochet 11 de 9 à mobutu oui c'est un
complot
ça existe sur le plan politique sur le
plan économique sur le plan militaire
aussi quand bush et blair disent il faut
attaquer ces dames parce qu'il va des
armes de destruction massive et qui
savent que c'est faux c'est un complot
c'est la définition du dictionnaire sur
un complot d'eux est mort il faut dire
que
c'est pas l'histoire ne se résume pas à
des complots et s'est même pas
l'essentiel tout à l'heure j'ai essayé
d'expliquer que le système économique et
social dans lequel on vit il est injuste
parce qu'il est basé sur le fait qu'un
pourcent décide ce qu'on va produire
dans les usines et ailleurs de comment
va l'économie va être organisée qui va
avoir de l'argent qui va pas en avoir
mais ça c'est pas un complot ce sont des
règles de fonctionnement économique et
c'est pas quelque chose qu'il contribue
clair envoyé avec vos yeux de l'ancien
militant communiste où les choses comme
ça dont vous avez besoin c'est clair que
l'analyse de marx permet de comprendre
comment fonctionne l'économie et je suis
je pense qu'il faut éviter les lancers
d'étiquettes et que ce qui a marqué sur
votre fiche wikipédia ah oui
non mais que ce soit à propos de moi aux
propos de n'importe qui je n'ai pas
honte
je crois que il faut réfléchir avec son
cerveau et on a intérêt à ce qu un
public large se pose des questions sur
comment fonctionne l'économie comment
fonctionne la politique comment se
décident les guerres est aussi étudié
l'histoire qui permet énormément de
comprendre l'époque actuelle donc sans
les étiquettes oui je pense que
l'économie
marque c'est très bien expliqué comment
se sait qu'il y en a qui sont très
riches qui sont très pauvres et qui a un
lien entre les deux c'est des vases
communicants la urgo avant marx ou en
même temps mais je crois pas qu'ils se
connaissaient avait dit c'est de l'enfer
des pauvres qui est fait le paradis des
riches donc c'est un bon résumé de
l'exploitation et je crois que
il faut
pas expliquer ça en termes de complot
qu'il ya quelques personnes dans une
bande des banquiers ou des juifs ou des
illuminati qui sens d'une canne et qui
décide qu'on va faire une crise comme ça
on va et des choses pareilles ça c'est
des fantasmes et on voit beaucoup de
fantasmes et de théories du complot pour
expliquer le monde pour une raison bien
simple c'est que les médias ne
permettent pas de comprendre le monde
les médias cachent à chaque guerre la
vérité cache le fonctionnement de
l'économie je vais on invite tout le
temps des airs et des économistes qui
sereine que le 1% à raison il n'y a pas
d'alternative et tous les autres sont
sont boycottés donc évidemment que les
gens se posent des questions comme ils
n'ont pas la réponse ils vont chercher
sur un an net sur internet on peut
trouver de bonnes choses et de moins
bonnes et forcément ils peuvent tomber
dans des pièges et c'est très important
effectivement d'étudier l'histoire mais
aussi l'économie les stratégies de
guerre parce que moi je pense que
souvent on dit ce truc l'astre compliqué
les gens vont comprendre donc on
simplifie non il faut essayer de
communiquer l'essentiel de donner des
faits dû permettre aux gens de réfléchir
dans un langage simple avec des mots que
tout le monde comprend et tout le monde
peut comprendre moi j'ai déjà donné des
formations sur l'économie ou la
philosophie ou les stratégies gay à des
ouvriers qui avaient arrêté les écoles à
l'étude à 16 ans à des ménagères qui
avait jamais fait d'études et donc tout
le monde peut comprendre ça et je vais
dire mais gens d'en bas parfois
comprendront beaucoup mieux le fond des
choses que les gens qui croient qu'ils
avec le grand d'éducation ils savent
tout et je crois que c'est ça pour
répondre à cette histoire du complot les
médias n'informant pas refusant le débat
avec les gens qui défendent d'autres
points de vue une autre analyse d'autres
sources tout simplement que il provoque
ce sentiment on nous cache tout donc on
va chercher des choses 12h à 14h alors
que le monde est parfaitement
reconnaissable et analysable s'il ya une
vraie info correct et ses sacs avec un
v6 action on essaie de faire donner aux
citoyens les moyens eux même d'analyser
le monde et de se faire leur opinion
vous avez parlé des balkans on va
revenir sur sur les balcons est ce que
vous connaissez général wesley clark
bien sûr parce que vous connaissez ces
déclarations ah oui qu'est-ce qu'il est
cité dans qu'est ce qu'il a dit qui est
ce monsieur qu'est ce qu'il a fait bah
ouais ce l'écart qui est un général qui
a bombardé la yougoslavie et j'étais sur
place pendant que chez bettane ans il
était le chef d'état-major de l'otan
donc c'était le chef des opérations et
je peux témoigner que c'est un criminel
de guerre il y avait eu six
internationale il aurait dû être jugé
parce que j'étais sur place j'ai vu des
hôpitaux bombardés j'ai vu qu'ils
étaient venus bombardé un hôpital j'ai
vu une infirmière en entendant qu'il y
avait des sirènes slim était en congé
mais ma place et à l'hôpital la rive à
l'hôpital y reviennent bombardé une
deuxième fois pas bombarder je veux dire
avec des bombes à fragmentation donc là
d'un côté c'était vraiment terrible j'ai
vu des gosses j'ai vu des usines
détruites comme par hasard toutes les
usines qui était nationalisé yougoslave
ont été détruites et toutes les usines
qui appartenait à des multinationales
étrangères cela était intact donc c'est
vraiment une guerre économique
dégueulasse et wesley clark était un
criminel de guerre ça c'est clair ça
donne d'autant plus de poids à la
déclaration très intéressante qui l'a
fait en 2005 et en 2007 j'ai plus croît
2005 il était interviewé par une radio
que je connais où j'avais été qui
s'appelle démocratie non par amy goodman
états unis et il a fait une confidence
très intéressante il était à la retraite
tout de suite après la yougoslavie et
donc ils s'amènent au pentagone fin 2001
après le 11 septembre novembre décembre
je crois mire la date dans un de mes
bouquins il rencontre en général avec
qui ils étaient copains et ce général
lui dit voilà je viens de recevoir un
mémo d'en haut donc de rome ce fait le
ministre la guerre et le memo 10 nous
allons nous états unis nous allons
prendre sept pays en commençant par
l'irak l'afghanistan
le soudan la libye le liban la somalie
et pour finir les rangs sept pays en
2001 donc
ça veut dire que tout ça a été
programmée après on dit oui c'est parce
que saddam a des ambitions massive parce
que le chaudron souci où ils font ça où
kadhafi maintient c'est tout programmer
et après on saute sur le prétexte où on
fabrique le prétexte est donc wesley
clark c'est un aveu très intéressant
parce que c'est pas un type de gauche
c'est pas un complotiste il dit lui-même
voilà les états unis ils ont un plan
pour recoloniser tout le monde
arabo-musulman et ça on l'a analysé dans
un bouquin qui s'appelle la stratégie du
chaos impérialisme et islam les états
unis décident de contrôler ce qu'ils
appellent la rhk islamique moyen-orient
maghreb mais aussi la corne de l'afrique
avec deux pays stratégique le soudan le
soudan et la somalie et l'afghanistan et
le pakistan qui sont l'afghanistan c'est
la plaque tournante au point de vue
stratégique de de l'asie pour menacer la
chine et le pakistan
c'est la zone centrale pour les voix de
l'océan indien parce que on parle
toujours en termes de pays au niveau
stratégique mais il faut penser en
termes d'océan les routes maritimes y en
a 60 % maintenant qu'ils sont dans
l'océan indien c'est plus atlantique
l'atlantique ou même le pacifique c'est
l'océan indien qui est le centre du
monde et donc le pakistan voilà mais je
m'entraîne bien par le collier de perles
oui c'est ça sécurisation du collier de
perles ou et voilà les chinois ayant peu
de matières premières et une économie
qui se développe énormément
sont obligés de se procurer des matières
premières là où il y en a et donc c'est
par là que les états unis veulent les
tenir évidemment les états unis ne sont
pas tout à fait fou et ils ne peuvent
pas imaginer d'attaquer militairement la
chine ce serait impossible donc il faut
l'encercler il faut la priver au pouvoir
la priver de ses approvisionnements en
matières premières dont il ya une guerre
pour les matières premières est ce que
la chine veut faire c'est un réseau de
ports en eau profonde parce que le
commerce maritime international
maintenance et des ports en eau profonde
et voilà tout ce collier de perles
effectivement tout s'est tu
cette chaîne de port en eau profonde
les états unis dès qu'il ya un
partenaire ou un allié pour la chine il
essaie de déstabiliser coup d'état
guerre civile ou corruption pour essayer
de prendre le contrôle ils l'ont fait
récemment au sri lanka c'est vraiment
très important pour eux de contrôler
l'océan indien mais papouasie nouvelle
guinée qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire en ce moment tu vas spécialistes se
passe
comment ça va se terminer
sur le plan des guerres sur le plan de
terrorisme nous on n'en est rien
le plan des guerres parce que là on voit
la russie faire énormément de mouvement
voit la chine construire des
porte-avions fixe avec des îles
artificielles et on voit les contrats
d'armement un petit peu les alliances
souder un peu à gauche et à droite
nous l'europe au mieux on commence à se
terminer l on veut la guerre on va pas
la guerre cette personne peut le prédire
l'histoire n'est pas prévisible sur ce
plan là les deux peuvent arriver il ya
toute une série
j'ai publié il ya quelques mois une
série d'articles obama craint un conflit
mondial je crois salle titre analysant
un discours très étonnant qu'il a fait
au moment où il
il a présenté l'accord conclu avec
l'iran il avait évidemment une
opposition très forte des républicains
au congrès même chez les démocrates
aussi qui disait il faut pas faire un
accord avec l'iran il faut les attaquer
il faut continuer et il a dit obama si
vous attaquez l'iran un ça va pas du
tout
faire le bien des états unis parce que
l'iran nous résistent il ne s'est pas
mis à genoux 2 ça va nous discréditer au
point de vue international jusqu'à
présent on a pu compter sur l'aide de la
france et des européens pour faire la
guerre contre la libye ou la syrie mais
si on fait ça tout seul tant donné que
peugeot accompagner une rêve que d'une
chose c'est des contraintes téhéran ils
vont pas nous suivre c'est fini les
allemands non plus n'en veulent pas
donc il a dit à ses opposants aux états
unis il faut
arrêter de penser qu'on peut faire la
guerre contre l'iran et il a dit aussi
une chose intéressante et il a dit on va
pas pouvoir contre contrées comme ça la
volonté des russes et des chinois
indéfiniment les chinois il possède une
grande partie de la dette des états unis
parce que l'état des états unis est un
état en faillite s'il n'y a pas les
pétromonarchies et la chine pour
financer sa dette l'économie est en fait
littéralement et donc il a dit voilà si
on fait ça on va affaiblir terriblement
les états unis alors on se trouve
maintenant dans une période historique
très importante et très dangereuse en
fait il ya deux courants aux états unis
il ya le courant qui dit
nous sommes en déclin économiquement
financièrement militairement il faut
essayer d'être malin il faut faire des
guerres sans que cela se voie trop il
faut toujours avoir des alliés il faut
essayer de neutraliser ce les puissances
qui pourrait s'opposer il faut faire la
guerre intelligemment ça veut dire aussi
par la corruption par la cia par des
guerres civiles et de la façon la moins
visible possible ça c'est en courant
c'est obama c'est ben régine ski des
gens comme ça l'autre courant c'est le
grand nez au col on va dire mouche mais
hillary clinton elle est plutôt de
secours en live pas croire ce passait
pas républicain ou démocrate
bernie sanders et les commandes dans ce
oui non là je pense que ça là je voterai
pour lui aux états unis si j'étais là
mais je veux dire que les neocon ont un
plan que au contraire il faut aller à la
confrontation avec la russie qu'il faut
pas laisser faire poutine et donc on le
provoque qu'on est en train de le
provoquer de toutes les manières pour
essayer de faire une escalade est ce les
néo comme sont décidés à faire ce qu'il
faut pour briser la résistance de la
russie de la chine de l'iran bien
entendu de l'au delà il nous emmène vers
une troisième guerre mondiale pas
programmer ou voulu mais quand on lance
une escalade contre d'autres puissances
de cette manière là quand on refuse de
négocier et trouver des solutions
diplomatiques c'est clair que ça peut
mener sur un conflit et pointe les
préconisations pour éviter le conflit
épouvantable
la chose qui manque terriblement en
europe et aux états unis moment je parle
en tant qu'européen c'est un mouvement
anti guerre
il y a eu des manifestations j'en
parlais avec des millions de gens dans
le monde contre la guerre du vietnam
encore en 2003 contre la guerre en irak
mais à part ça quand les états unis ou
la france attaque un pays et que ce pays
soit une démocratie ou en dictature ça
ne change rien parce que c'est pas une
question passe à ces guerres pour le
fric quand on attaque des pays quand on
fait la guerre il ya personne dans les
rues maintenant c'est ça qui est
dramatique c'est que on a eu dans le
passé des mouvements anti guerre
puissant dans les années 30 dans les
années 50 et encore après on a eu des
dockers qui refusait de charger les
armements l'ouvrier qui se mettaient en
grève on a eu les sabotages de train on
a eu des mouvements solidarité très
importante on a eu des appels
d'intellectuels pour la paix des
réunions des forums bertrand russell
tribunaux tout ça est maintenant c'est
complètement disparu et il ya un
phénomène terrible en france et dans les
autres pays européens
c'est que la gauche qui devrait être le
faire mais je tends pas de monsieur
hollande ça je parle pas de ça c'est pas
la gauche pour moi mais même à gauche du
ps les gens qui devraient être en
première ligne contre la guerre pour la
paix pour le dialogue international pour
le respect de la souveraineté des
nations
bascule et soutiennent les guerres de
l'otan dans wii vous faire quelque chose
les indicateurs et ceci et cela comme si
le but des états unis et de la france
était d'amener la démocratie partout
dans le monde ils font ça avec l'aide de
l'arabie saoudite et du qatar donc
forcément il se paye la gueule des gens
donc je crois que ça c'est le drame
maintenant la gauche a complètement
capituler devant les guerres que
j'appelle coloniale n'ose plus dire que
on nous ment à chaque guerre et n'osent
plus organiser la solidarité avec les
pays du sud et là on revient à cette
phrase de break que je suis tout le
temps il y a une mentalité coloniale une
mentalité arrogante en france et en
europe nous les blancs les bons on sait
ce qu'il faut faire partout dans le
monde on sait ce que les arabes les
africains le latine doit faire mais non
on est en droit en saurez plus que vous
qu'on aurait la solution laissez les se
débrouiller pour résoudre leurs
problèmes et ça l'absence d'un mouvement
anti guerre pour moi c'est une chose
terrible parce que comme je le disais on
est sur le sentier de la guerre ça peut
arriver ce n'est pas une fatalité mais
la résistance est né ou derrière
question conseil pour les jeunes
générations pour durcir l'esprit
critique oui ça change et ça c'est
l'essentiel je crois que la jeune
génération
a vraiment intérêt
si elle veut vivre dans un monde qu'ils
soient pas épouvantable au niveau des
guerres de la destruction de la nature
et de cette manière de répandre la haine
que tout le monde se déteste dans tous
les sens je crois que la jeune
génération a vraiment intérêt à prendre
en main son combat pour la justice pour
la paix pour la nature et que le combat
il passe par la question de l'info est
donc ainsi action c'est de ça qu'on
s'occupe on est un média c'est ça notre
métier on va dire
est pas possible de faire la guerre sans
manipuler les gens donc il est très
important de vérifier les infos et je
parle de guerre déclarée ou d'en
déclarer de guerre militaires ou de
guerre sociale ou culturelle c il faut
vérifier les infos absolument ifs et
c'est tout à fait possible il faut que
l'info devienne quelque chose qui n'est
pas réservé aux experts aux
professionnels mais devienne une
activité citoyenne c'est trop important
l'info pour notre vie aujourd'hui et
demain à tous pour la laisser aux mains
de gens pour qui c'est soit du fric ce
soit des intérêts de propagande il faut
que l'info soit faite par les citoyens
je pense que ça devrait commencer à
l'école mais là je rêve et donc il faut
organiser des ateliers parallèles ou
avec les profs qui sont motivés là
dessus mais en parallèle il faut
organiser des ateliers pour apprendre à
regarder la tv ou les images les
manipulations que ça peut entraîner pour
apprendre à faire une analyse critique
sur les infos courseaux à chercher les
sources à chercher l'autre version à
écouter les méchants et à se faire son
opinion par soi même je pense c'est
quelque chose que j très souvent c'est
philippe g on veut se battre c'est utile
mais chose ben les méchants c'est
toujours ceux qui sont pas d'accord avec
nous ce qu'ils sont pas d'accord de
donner l'heure le pétrole gratuitement
ou le cuivre ou le coltane où les le
canal de suez ou le canal de panama les
méchants c'est ce qu'ils sont pas
d'accord avec le 1% des multinationales
c'est cela qui sont diabolisés et donc
je crois que si on veut
vraiment comme je le dis
créer un monde et je pense vraiment que
c'est possible quand je sais pas mais je
pense vraiment que c'est possible créer
un monde où il y aura plus
l'exploitation et tous les uns contre
les autres et la haine et la destruction
de la nature je pense que l'info est la
première des batailles et c'est pour ça
que le premier conseil que je donne aux
jeunes et tout le monde c'est
d'appliquer cette idée prendre en main
la bataille de l'info c'est à dire nous
sommes tous des journalistes le chocolat
merci
[Musique]
parent
non
m
[Musique]